from the moment the Millennium Falcon
blasted away on screen some 40-plus
years ago Star Wars fans have dreamed of
piloting the fastest hunk of junk in the
galaxy these guys are making that dream
a reality
welcome to the full-scale Falcon cockpit
my name is Greg Dietrich I'm the project
build lead I guess you can say for the
full-scale Falcon cockpit replica what
you see right right behind me we're
trying to take the prop from the Star
Wars film and bring it into a real-life
in such a way that people can actually
walk around in it interact with it be
amazed by it for the past six years
Dietrich Pilate and a group of fellow
fans have been building a full-sized
version of the famous spaceship part by
intergalactic part believe and I started
the project May 4 and if you're a fan
you know I'm a fourth now they have
nearly finished the cockpit we're trying
to stay true to what we see on screen
for me it's when you walk in for the
very first time you're immediately
transported back to the very first time
you saw whatever whatever film it
happened to be whether it was Star Wars
Empire Jedi and you were immediately
transported back to being a kid and
going wow you can totally sit in the
cockpit now and it's great being part of
it even seeing it every day it's still
pretty cool we are sitting in the actual
cockpit that that we've built is the
first time that two people have actually
sat here first time in two two and a
half years that the console has has been
in place the seats have been in place
feels pretty good actually
what we're looking at is the is the
actual I guess flight console we're on
screen the ship is actually flowing what
each one of these buttons does I have no
idea what we know for sure is that in
order to go into Lightspeed not warp
speed light speed you pull these four
down and you go
and it's not just the hyperdrive levers
there's a radar unit to spot imperial
star destroyers and hatches that open
and close today Diedrich is putting
final touches on a set of pads that ring
the cockpit entrance we do that then one
goes here one goes here here all the way
around 19 total going all the way around
I actually gauge doubt this deep cut
right right right here I just basically
took a knife and I went like this to the
actual insulation foam and then when I
covered with a shop towel modge podge I
kind of tucked it in there and once the
paint was on and the black wash was put
on you can see what a dirty look so you
go from that to that
in a matter of minutes and each pad has
to be done by hand one at a time but
what I really enjoy about is that each
pad has its own character has its own
life has its own story to tell which is
a lot of fun and that's what makes the
project fun to make it as realistic and
as interactive as possible Pilate has
rigged the craft with sound and lights
lots of lights I've lost count to be
honest I'd have to say probably over 500
lights some blink some turn on and off
with a satisfying click the lights are
part of the full-scale falcon team's
devotion to the fine art of something
that set builders call grebe lee's all
of the details that you see whether it's
these trays here or this piece that I
call the laser gun or the cockpit laser
gun this this grebe Lee set right here
that's exactly what that's called we
don't know what it is so we call it
agreeably one of my favorite graves in
the whole and the whole cockpit is this
guy right here this this particular
grebe Lee has has been redesigned redone
I think five or six times but it's one
of my favorites because we finally
identified what it actually is and it's
an auto pilot clutch out of a fighter it
sitsit just sits there and it's just
it's one of my absolute favorite
favorite pieces you'd be forgiven if you
thought they were building this in a
galaxy far far away but the full-scale
Falcon is being constructed in a garage
here we are located in Huntsville
Alabama which is the spacing cat space
and rocket capital in the world just
right down the road from us is the space
rocket center you would ever come into
town you can see the very very large
Saturn 5 rocket Wernher von Braun was
here and he's really what helped the
u.s. start their space program I can't
think of a better place for the Falcon
to be the city than this base and rocket
capital of the world but Dietrich and
Pilate do get assistance with schematics
and grebes from volunteer fans from
around the world the project is thinking
on a life of its own it started with
just me in my garage once it began to
take off once people will I hate this of
this this guy serious all of a sudden
people from not only around here but
people from Seattle Baltimore Dallas
England all wanted to get involved which
is good because Dietrich who works as a
graphic designer and Pilate who also has
a day job can only do so much in their
free time this isn't a full-time job I
got a full-time job in an office where I
sit all day long when I get the
opportunity I come here and I build and
I have fun no detail is too small and
that can be a problem because the
Millennium Falcon is constantly changing
the actors during shoots might knock off
a part so they might glue it on they
might glue it on wrong
they might not glue it on at all and so
they might put on another part it's so
every scene changes and so it's hard to
kind of say this is the definitive
Falcon because it always changes it
originally started as the new hope
cockpit and then we said let's go for
the Empire version that's the
fan-favorite we're trying to be a screen
accurate as we can get
really good feeling of course with the
new movies including the new solo there
are always new Millennium Falcon details
to study the first time I watch a new
Star Wars movie I just let it be Star
Wars like I just I just let it hit I let
I want to I want that first viewing to
be just the fun viewing then after that
once I've gotten my once I've gotten my
Star Wars experience then I'll sit down
and go okay what's what's different
these guys know a lot about the
Millennium Falcon from movie quotes from
a point 5 past light speed do the Kessel
run in under 12 parsecs
she might not look like much but she got
where it counts - details on the
original parts used to build the first
set take the neat chairs behind the
pilot seats they were originally made
from martin-baker mark 4 ejection seats
found in early jets no they're not not
cheap at all the martin-baker chair
itself between 15 to 25 thousand dollars
it's more cost-effective to just build
one this is not an actual injection see
this is a replica mostly wood which I
built has removable pads on it you've
got you've got 3d printed parts 3d
printed parts here this is just a
mock-up of the headpiece but the most
famous part of the chair believe it or
not is the actual Tupperware lid that's
it's dead center of where the person's
head rests that is an actual Tupperware
lid that level of detail is what makes
the build so unique parts that can't be
found are made by hand by 3d printer and
with a laser cutter the cockpit is made
out of mostly 3/4 inch plywood that's
for all of the framing the panels are
made from MDF which is multi density
fiberboard the grebe leaves and the
details you see are mostly acrylic MDF
or 3d printed I would say the cockpit
way is probably a thousand pounds maybe
1500 III to be honest I really don't
know I don't want it fallen on me but I
really don't know how how much it weighs
how much longer do I think I have on it
6 months maybe
maybe two I don't know and believe it or
not the cockpit is just the beginning
the ultimate goal is to build the the
entire ship the actual full-scale ship
is 80 feet wide 114 feet long and 30
feet tall at the top of the radar so
it's not small
that's just three little things they're
holding us back time space and money how
much money have I spent I really don't
want to say because probably between
thirty to sixty thousand dollars I would
say and a lot of that is just doing
something over and over again realizing
that oh we got the part wrong I have to
take it off and I have to order
something because I have to redo the
part so why do we want to build
something like this I don't know maybe
to capture that same feeling that we had
when we were eight years old where were
10 years old we were 12 years old
it takes us away from that from reality
and takes us to a time when we didn't
have to worry about bills we didn't have
to worry about the politicians we didn't
have to worry but we weren't bombarded
this takes all of that away and and
maybe that's what it is in the real
world if you could if you could just
pull the floor Leivers Labor's back and
get out of here I think well I think we
would do it
you